on the hill tonight for the giants
making his second opening
start of the year will be zach littell
mattel
uh
21st appearance that he's had this year
he's a big guy six three two thirty he's
25 years old his in his second year at
the big league level you take your bats
against him you're going to see a mid to
high 90s fastball that he can sink and
cut he's also got a slider and a split
finger fastball
we're underway in san francisco josh
rojas leads it off a good start
lines it into that sun yastremski chases
it down rojas heads for third
[Applause]
great start for the diamondbacks
littel has loaded the base of the first
three have reached ahead of walker
[Applause]
sky to very shallow center and it drops
in for a base hits everybody had to hold
up just to make sure rojas is home with
the diamondbacks strike first
as drubal cabrera starts at third
but the first five in the ball game have
reached mattel walks in iran make it two
nothing andrew bailey runs out there
as they get long up in the bullpen
peralta gets a crackdown
off litalin into center carson's home
christian walker coming in right behind
and the diamondbacks have a four nothing
lead
how about this first start
on the hill tonight for the diamondbacks
will be alex young the
27 year old left-hander 63-220 pounder
this is what he has done at 26 games
this year all out of the bullpen
uh 3-4-5 era look at this walks 15 walks
in 28th two-thirds that is an issue with
him
he's got good stuff as he's averaging
more than a strikeout at any
they've moved into the bullpen for this
year
right center field that's going to drop
base hit to tell monte fields it on the
hop
slater gets the giants going
waves at that one and there's your
shutdown inning for alex young a zero on
the board it's four nothing defense
[Music]
four-nothing arizona leading
nasty curveball and buster tags it out
[Applause]
standing ovation in the long section
pitching for sacramento state
and that time away from the game got him
to come back healthy josh rojas the base
hit off the left-hander
and josh is two for two
christian walker got a gift hit in the
opening inning
walker got a fastball and drilled it to
left that's gonna get to the wall
diamondbacks on the move rojas is home
here comes cattell martay here's the
throw and it's not in time
christian walker knocks in two more make
it six nothing diamondbacks and here's
his drupal 3-2
he's lifted out to deep left center
still on the run is duggar he won't get
there and then one hops the wall
seven-nothing d-backs
four in the first and now three home in
the second
[Music]
we ought to get one run home
[Applause]
but flores scores
rojas throws out solano and belt goes to
third and the jets are down seven to one
oh here's dugger hitting 293.
he crushes one high and deep way back
there
that run
is wet
seven to three
arizona
two down nobody on
struck him out again with the curveball
six pitch inning
for sammy long the giants are coming
back with you scramski posey and brandon
crawford
left that curveball up
rojas for one ame
turns it
[Applause]
and alex young is through three d-bags
holding a 7-3 lead ball machine one
slider machine
kelly off the end of the bat slater's
gonna run this one down and sammy long
has another one two three inning he's
set down seven in a row
so a little momentum on the side of the
giants who trails seven to three
it's this one out the other way it backs
up perrault in left field
and we're through four d-backs holding a
7-3 lead
second and third one out for josh
reddick who is over two
chops that one over the first base side
no chance to get cabrera who's home with
run number eight
3-2
and he missed with the change-up ball
four that was a great take
bases are loaded
in 20-19
that one hit him corbin recovers and
leaves him loaded
wild ride but it stays eight to three
reaches down and just pokes that into
left field josh is three for four
called strike three and he's still
looking for a not speed pitch
two for three in this game on the ground
to short so austin slater's good play
and then a good pitch from connor mines
keeps the diamondbacks from scoring
on this beautiful san francisco knight
8-3 d-backs
here's solano
solano into left field base hit
giants
down by four
games not over fans are going to use
jason vossler here
he pulls that one and a diving attempt
but it's off the glove solano is going
to come around third he will score
that pinch hitter pays off
it's a three-run game it's only the
sixth inning those are tough places to
pitch reno albuquerque salt lake
he's survived so far martay deep into
triples alley
and that's three outs on seven pitches
for corbin martin in a scoreless seventh
it's eight to five diamondbacks
and here comes jazz
as the giants have been playing catch-up
all night long
it's a high drive to right is it fair
down to nine it is a great slam
into the water
can you believe it
the giants have come from seven to
nothing behind
and yostremski
has put them ahead
he would always reply
it's a fair ball buster posey and the
ball game is over